il ya quelque chose qui est pas très
populaire en france et pas pourquoi
c'est l'expérimentation c'est tout ou
rien je suis pour l'expérimentation
non mais faisons le sur certaines zones
mais faisons le la situation est telle
que maintenant il faut faire preuve
d'imagination
moi je change d'avis un peu comme vous
je change de vie toutes les semaines se
disent qu'il faut légaliser ou pas il ya
autant d'arguments fortement con mais
j'aimerais bien avoir là une remontée de
terrain qui m'explique en quoi c'est
efficace ou inefficaces mais ça ne peut
pas durer comme ça il ya des quartiers
entiers qui échappent mais va la révéler
aux forces de l'ordre c'est pas possible
nan mais c'est à la vérité c'est qu'on a
plus de courage pour rien du tout pas
plus que pour lutter contre l'insécurité
contre pour lutter contre
l'ensauvagement pour lutter contre la
drogue enfin j'aimerais bien qu'on me
demandait même pas pour l'un contre la
désindustrialisation et la drogue et
antalya unien une usine qui viendra de
bridgestone qui ne ferment fait rien et
c'est vrai donc s'ils voulaient il ya
une espèce de le gouverner avec un drap
le gouvernement est mobilisé pour vous
expliquer pourquoi il est impossible de
faire quoi que ce soit voilà et je le
président de république parler à juste
titre de séparatisme je pense que cette
économie de la drogue fait partie d'une
sorte de séparatisme économique parce
que effectivement je rejoins ce qui a
été dit la drogue c'est une économie
souterraine c'est un écosystème qui vis
de lui même par lui même sur lui même et
qui contribue à l'exclusion des
quartiers alors moi je crois pas que la
solution réside dans la dépénalisation
je crois plutôt que la solution réside
dans le redémarrage de l'économie parce
que qu'est ce qui pousse ces jeunes
finalement à trafiquer de la drogue pour
gagner les mollets les sommes qu'on a
entendu tout à l'heure c'est précisément
parce que notre société est infoutue de
leur offrir un autre avenir que le
chômage les dessine rôle et ses
délibérations donc déjà déjà si on
commençait à avoir une politique
volontariste une politique économique
arrêter de faire fermer les usines
donner un avenir à ces jeunes je dis pas
que ça réglerait tout le problème
il aura une grande partie du problème
tiens qui vous donner du boulot aux
jeunes des quartiers que sissoko
ardemment vous est ce qui sous peu vous
êtes raciste ou d'habitude c'est raté là
ce soir
il reconnaît qu'ils veulent se lever le
matin pour bosser ses mangas mais que
ses mots
[Applaudissements]